[Musique]
vous connaissez mes amis non vous allez
adorer
dans dix jours et retrouver mon boulot
pépère j'ai fait pas des problèmes nous
espérer que le reste de la police
française n'est pas quand vous
ici en amérique on suit scrupuleusement
les règles
ça va pas de plaire à bien avec le
règlement n'est pas forcé d'être
toujours eu deux dents au kenzi que ça
et qu'on monterait à celui qui a deux
matches assez bon j'y vais j'y vais
c'est mon fils croyez moi en fait une
bonne et comme ici tout de suite
puisqu'on est en cours
vous connaissez miami non vous allez
adorer
cebu les français willy de belleville
ravi de vous rencontrer chez nous tu
n'es pas un vrai flic toi tu es là pour
observer
est ce que t'es dingue tout est
fortement quoi
donc j'ai pas le droit d'avoir un gun de
lebron interroger des témoins en
profiter qu'est-ce que je peux faire
alors rien du tout
wauquiez une voiture mais n'ont pas
traîné go c'est là ma voiture c'est ça
ta caisse même deux flics à miami on va
pas le faire en fait